[Music]
hey what's up
mkbhd here and this is the surface duo
screen on in all of its super sweet
hinge
well-built ultra thin glory
it's an amazing piece of hardware but
actually using it as i have been for the
past
two to three weeks is a bit of a mixed
bag so i'm just gonna come right off the
top and say it
i don't think most people should buy
this and that's fine i think there's a
lot of
pretty cool devices out there that just
aren't right for most people to
buy and use that's all right but now
that you know that right off the top of
the review
i want to approach this a little bit of
a different way a little more conceptual
and just highlight the good the bad and
the ugly
which actually for for surface duo i'm
gonna adjust a little it'll be
the good the meh
and the bad because there are some
really good pieces and some really good
ideas
then there's some meh stuff that didn't
really quite work out
and then there's some really bad too
but the most interesting thing is almost
all of this comes from it being
a first generation device this is the
first surface duo it's the first
foldable phone from microsoft it's the
first android phone from microsoft
it's the first dual screen pocketable
device with no cover screen like this
the first
razer thin phone with a 360 degree hinge
and two five-inch displays like this so
it's the first
at a lot of things but the thing is it's
the second generation of most things
that's the most interesting or at least
the most telling like that's when you
get to see all of the learnings about
what went well and what didn't go well
and what they can change versus what
they can't
that's what's exciting i am literally
already looking forward to
surface duo 2 like a lot but
let me just show you what went well and
what didn't with this one
[Music]
[Applause]
so what's the good well if you remember
the the first impressions video where
nobody was allowed to turn it on
uh i was raving about that hardware and
that hinge
and i am sticking by that the crazy
thinness
is obviously the first thing that
strikes you it's barely thicker than a
usb-c
port on each side and then the
360-degree hinge
it's awesome it has this smoothness but
also a
firmness to it where it can stop in any
position that's just awesome so
props to the hinge engineers and the
result is
all these postures these different modes
that you can
hold or prop up the device there's book
mode
horizontal with you know one screen on
each side kind of like a book like this
there is compose mode so keyboard on one
screen content on the other
single screen mode thanks to the hinge
flip it all the way around 360 degrees
pick a screen
there's also tent mode and peak mode and
right as you get into all these postures
things do get pretty complex because now
the device is responding to a variety of
orientation changes
and state of fold changes and we'll get
more into the bugs of course later in
this video but
when it works well it's really cool it's
really nice
you can open up an app on one screen and
literally do
anything you want on the other screen
you can read
two things at once you can watch a video
on one screen and take notes on it
on the other screen you can move the
video to the other side and
move the notes back to the other side
you can just mess around you can you can
close something
and multitask while the video keeps
going you can always switch what screen
something is on
or even drag to the middle and span it
between two screens now not every app
looks good spanned across both screens
matter of fact
most don't like right now it's up to
developers to get in
and update their apps and take advantage
of this multitasking experience
which may not happen very quickly
depending on how popular this is but
if you look at microsoft suite of apps
the 365 suite outlook is a really good
example where you span it across and you
get email on one side and you can
you can use your calendar and view
single events on one side and the
calendar on the other
it's great so for me and surface duo i
found i tend to start by opening it up
in book mode
and then i slowly get into whatever i'm
doing which is usually just on one side
and then it's kind of awkward having the
other side just kind of staring at me
with nothing happening
wasting power so i often switch over to
single screen mode and use it like that
and that's cool it keeps the volume
rocker and the power button on the right
hand side
it's not bad basically it's just a
little wider than normal for typing
which i will again get to in a bit
but hey there's always compose mode for
when i need to do some really extended
typing like crafting
a beautiful tweet with no typos or you
know writing an email really the best
example of this and microsoft knows
multitasking is a huge
upside for surface duo but samsung does
it too on the fold
is the app pairs so they call them app
groups and you can launch
two apps at the same time two different
apps and you can come up with all sorts
of sweet combos and great ideas
for how to use these all you gotta do to
make one of your own is pick an app hold
it down
select app group pick the second app to
pair them together
then pick which screen you want each one
to be on then create it
and just like that i'm feeling like an
absolute productivity machine
pulling out the surface duo flipping it
open launching a calendar in the email
at the same time
and yes that's easily my most common app
group it's just so good it makes so much
sense with the dual screens
typically when you're multitasking on a
phone if you even do this at all
you're like dragging two different
windows around sort of
abstractly and even on the fold you can
do three at once but how many people are
really doing that
with this it's just kind of staring you
in the face like you have to
you have to multitask so that's what it
does well
really well that's the core of what
makes it a surface so now let's get into
this stuff that is uh
meh so the bezels a lot of people out
here are really not feeling it
i definitely wish they were thinner but
you also have to realize the side bezels
uh are actually a measure against
accidental touches that's about as thin
as you could get them without starting
to touch the screen all the time but i
just think the top and bottom bezels
are a little thick then pocketability so
okay it is two 5.6 inch displays but as
you can tell they're very
wide for if it was a normal 5.6 inch
phone
plus those bezels so the whole thing is
shaped like a passport that you might be
more likely to put in a back pocket
so for me it does stick out a bit in the
front pocket
i've kind of gotten used to it uh but at
this point there's there's some big
phones out there and this one sticks out
above all the rest as
a little bit tough on smaller pockets
maybe a little bit narrower would have
been
more palatable and then typing overall
yeah it's it's all right like it's a
it's a mixed bag like i said so the
compose mode where you're just typing on
the bottom screen and you have whatever
content on the top screen
that's fine and microsoft they partnered
with swiftkey on this keyboard for
android that sort of smartly adapts to
whatever posture you're in and shifts
the keyboard accordingly so if you're in
book mode
you can't really type with one hand all
over that one side screen so if you need
to
it shifts the keyboard over and on one
side you can reach all the keys
it's still way slower than two thumb
typing
but it's better than nothing the only
bummer here is
uh other third party keyboards don't
have this optimization yet so my
keyboard of choice is g
board and it just looks silly trying to
span across the whole thing so typing
was hit or miss gotta use swiftkey and
then performance
it's you know look we knew it wasn't
gonna be the best performer it was in
development for a whole year so it has
last year's specs snapdragon 855 and six
gigs of ram
it's not going to benchmark the highest
we knew that but i think just using it
you start to see performance issues and
i think my biggest performance issue
here was just
overall fluidity at 60 hertz and sure
that's partially because i am coming
from other smooth high refresh rate
flagships
including the new galaxy fold actually
but i'm also just noticing a ton of
little hiccups and lags while just
moving around
and multitasking i think this device
that's geared specifically for
multitaskers could have hit us with a
little bit more than six gigs of ram
like if it was me i would have wanted
like 12 gigs of ram in this guy but yeah
if you're
used to flagship performance or any
other high-end performance from an
expensive phone
you kind of get it here but overall
meh and then battery life is also
you know kind of middle of the road
better than i thought it would be
actually so standby time
is pretty good it's a 3600 milliamp hour
battery so i find when i'm
opening it and using it like two screen
multitasking i can start to bleed
through battery pretty fast and i can
kill it in a day
now when i'm switching to one screen
mode which i did
more often than not which by the way is
kind of rough with some
car gps's like if you try to put it in
your dashboard it's kind of silly but
either way when i'm using it one screen
i'm not drawing power from the back
screen
as much so i'm actually getting better
battery life
when i do that and right now i'm at half
battery at 1 30 pm
it's acceptable but again you know you
don't have wireless charging you only
have
18 watt fast charging so overall the
battery
meh but then we get to the bad like the
stuff that it's truly terrible at
and i don't throw that word around very
often but it's when you get this first
gen stuff sometimes you're
just gonna not have things go well right
and so i'll even try to explore a little
bit why i think some of these things
went so bad so first of all the speaker
[Music]
the speaker is absolute trash and i
think it's pretty simple
there's just not enough room in here for
some great speakers
like it's a thin body they're not really
top or bottom mounted like you might
expect to find them
it's uh just at the top here in the
earpiece and the slot up there
that's it so at absolute maximum volume
it sounds like a normal smartphone
speaker at 50 volume
and inside a tin can like it's pretty
brutal not enough room for a good
speaker here
and then the camera so the camera is in
fact terrible the quality is trash
and we kind of knew it would be already
because it's like the opposite of
what the zenfone is doing so on the
zenfone 7 the huge main camera swivels
around and becomes
like basically the world's best selfie
camera on the surface duo
you swivel around the selfie camera and
it becomes
possibly the worst main camera you can
have at least
the worst i've seen in a 1400 phone
anyway and you know microsoft
does call it an adaptive 11 megapixel
camera so it can tell when it's taking a
selfie and optimized for faces
versus when it's taking a regular photo
but yeah all the optimization in the
world isn't going to save this you're
not going to make a webcam
feel like a big optically stabilized
sensor it's just not going to take good
photos but look it's not just the
quality of the photos this bad it's also
just the ergonomics of taking a photo
there's no back camera like we've
established so every time i want to take
a photo of something in front of me
i have to do this flip it around unlock
it
open the camera app and then it's going
to be in selfie mode so now i have to
try to swivel it around and get it to
flip and by the time i'm doing all this
half the time the shot is gone or i
don't even feel like taking a photo
anymore
so it felt like it actively discouraged
me from
taking photos and videos and really the
worst bug is trying to get it to switch
to
the front viewfinder you're supposed to
be able to double tap
to get it to switch but it still stays
in that selfie mode
so often and pretty much anywhere else
in the ui you can force it to switch
screens at any time by double tapping
the off screen
and it usually works great but i guess
in the camera it's not listening to the
double tap and the accelerometer is
difficult to get it to switch it's rough
and then there's a
there's a flash up there in the in the
top bezel just to
what why is there a flash is anyone
really using this for
nighttime photography but look microsoft
they know their audience right
this is the same company that has the
the biggest
most advertised feature of their new ear
pods
is the ability to swipe through
powerpoint slides like
the surface duo buyer doesn't really
take a ton of photos and videos and
stuff it's not a big deal
this will be fine for the occasional
video chat you know scanning documents
maybe a selfie once in a while but i
think the point is just leaving it at
that
is sacrificing what most people would
want which is like a
a nice set of cameras on the back for
what they've already
decided they want which is a nice thin
device with a 360 hinge that folds flat
and i think that's gonna hold it back i
mean don't get me wrong i still
raved about how thin it was in the
hardware and how much i love it
and i like that i could get creative and
prop it up in tent mode and get
videos of myself without needing
anyone's help even though the videos
were
garbagio quality that was kind of cool
but the theme that i'm getting at here
is overall practicality
suffering at the expense of folding it
in half
is the thing that's holding back all
first generation folding phones it's the
challenge for all of them and it's
definitely happening here
with surface duo this phone has no
wireless charging no
ip rating no real ecosystem around it
very little app support out of the gate
and even a lot of the little things you
might hope for
in a phone of this price no 5g
no headphone jack no high refresh rate
no super fast wireless charging not
great haptics
you know practicality is clearly
suffering to achieve
this form factor but in future
generations when this actually improves
and they're able to add back those
things that's when foldables will
actually have a convincing future
when it's not like you're sacrificing
and sacrificing
but you happen to get it to fold now
when the fold
is just another feature that'll be a
sweet future that's the day that's
that's what i'm looking forward to
so you know you do file this first one
in do not buy but keep an eye on it
because
i really think they're on to something i
like the dual screen thing it's the same
reason i sit in front of dual screen
monitors at my desk instead of an
ultrawide it's because
the productivity the staying in your
flow the compartmentalization
of having two screens it works it's
real and so i'm looking forward to the
next surface duo
and that's the review of the first one
thanks for watching
catch you guys the next one peace